hello my name is Brian Otis with rice
tech incorporated proper grand real
calibration is a very important aspect
to getting off on the right foot each
season and with rice tech seed that's no
exception as you know we're dealing with
lower than normal seeding rates so it's
very important to get your grain drill
calibrated so that you get a good start
each season so today we're going to go
through calibrating three major types of
grain drills an air cedar like you see
behind me we're going to go through a
John Deere type box drill and then
finally we're going to finish with a
Great Plains type box group okay so I'm
going to go through basically your
supply list of what you're going to need
for proper drill calibration first thing
you're going to need to do is look at
your bag of seed or the piece of paper
that comes with a mini bull and find out
what your seed per pound rate is for
this particular bag we know that we've
got twenty thousand two hundred and two
seed per pound okay so what you're going
to do is divide that number into your
seeding rate which in the case you know
depending on how many pounds heat
breaker your number of seed per acre you
divide that number by the number on the
bag and when you do that that's going to
give you the exact number of pounds per
acre that you need to plant once you
determine the number of seeds per pound
either in our pre-planning newsletter
that we send out annually on our website
at Rice techcom you can get or you can
download an Excel spreadsheet which is
our calibration worksheet which works
for any seed you want to plant in your
grain drill works for rice takes seed
works for soybean seed but you're going
to need to know the number of seat per
pound and the number or the pounds per
acre of seed that you want to plant
you'll enter that number into our
calibration worksheet and our worksheet
will give you the proper amount of seed
that you need to catch in the grain
drill
to ensure that you're properly
calibrated now at our website and in our
pre-planning newsletter we also provide
basic starting points for each type of
box grain group which based on previous
experience of our field tech and tech
reps out in the field we've determined
on Great Plains and John Deere drills a
good starting point with each type of
drills so that you can be in the
ballpark at least from where you want to
get started okay so for supplies that
you're going to need first you'll need a
tape measure you're going to need to
measure the circumference of the gauge
wheel or the transmission wheel that's
actually turning the drill second you're
going to need a ruler and this will
enable you to measure the COG so that
you can get a very accurate measurement
so to which meters the seed coming out
of the drill we recommend a metal ruler
in metric so it's in centimeters and
millimeters second you'll need a
calculator just to help you do some
basic calculations although if you
download the spreadsheet from our
website
the Excel spreadsheet will do that for
you
duct tape you'll need duct tape to mark
the transmission wheel because we will
be making a number of revolutions with
the gauge wheel or transmission wheel
this will just help you keep track and
where you're at finally in something
that most people probably don't have
will be a small electric scale in this
particular case you can use a postage
scale or this scale is just about just a
standard electric scale that you can
actually buy off the internet next just
a couple of cups to help move in seed
around on the drill to measure seed out
of the bag to pour into the drill in
order to measure the seed out of each of
the each of the seed cups under the Box
drill you can either use individual cups
to put under the cups you can use the
styrofoam cup as shown here or a
standard plastic Solo Cup or if you'd
rather you can use a catch catch can
which you can catch several row units at
one time and then you can pour it out
here at the ends
you know either one of these methods
will work fine and then finally once
you're calibrated we've come up with
these handy magnets that can you can
affixed to the lid in the box and you
can write down your settings so each
year when you come to recalibrate at the
beginning of the year you've got good
starting points from where you were set
last year so that in the following year
you'll know where to start and you can
calibrate the drill on your own okay
we're going to demonstrate proper
calibration of a Great Plains type box
true
okay in order to get started first you
need to make sure that the drill is
completely empty all the seat cups have
been cleaned out but then have been
moved back up to that first position
then you can go to our website and get
the approximate starting points for this
type of drill first thing you need to
know on the Great Plains is to make sure
that the transmission is in the lowest
setting so on this particular drill this
is a Great Plains 2020 we're going to be
in drive setting number one a
transmission setting number one then
because this is an eight inch model
drill we're going to make sure that our
knotch setting is at number sixty the
times these drills have quite a bit of
play I'm going to go all the way to zero
and then move it to sixty okay now this
is just going to be an approximate
starting point from this point we'll
begin our calibration and then make
small adjustments up or down depending
on which way we need to go okay the next
step is to get a proper measurement of
your gauge wheel on this particular
drill there's two gauge wheels one on
each side that run the transmission but
we just need to measure one of them
because typically they're the same so
the easiest way to do this is to get a
tape measure and a piece of duct tape
tape the tape measure to the gauge wheel
and the center spin it around until it
comes back and then get a measurement
this particular gauge wheel is seven
foot eleven and a half inches long as
we're going to convert that into inches
and then enter that into our and our
spreadsheet as our wheel circumference
okay once you get the circumference of
your drive wheel you can go online
download our get our spreadsheet off the
internet
and enter the circumference of the gauge
wheel you can also enter the number of
seats per pound which on your bag or on
your mini boat is a listing of the
number of seats per pound for your
particular lot of seed you'll put that
information in and then you're going to
divide this number number see per pounds
into the number of seats per acre that
you need to plant that will in turn give
you the number of pounds per acre that
you need to plant you'll plug that
number into the spreadsheet and it will
give you the number of grams you need to
catch from the predetermined number of
row units and turns of the the gauge
wheel and when you get that number then
you'll know that you're properly
calibrated we're going to come back to
the back side of the grill and we're
going to measure five seed cups so with
this particular drill it's a lot easier
to pull the tubes off of the road units
and it is to pull the tubes down from
the seat code we've got this handy catch
catch can hear so what I'm going to do
is pull five of these drop tubes off so
that they lay in this catch pin
if you choose to you can also use Solo
cups or get some help here - just hold
cups underneath these C cups if you
don't have a pan like this to use to
catch the C okay once you've got your
drop tube set and the drills cleaned out
you're going to need to go ahead and put
some seed in only put enough seed in to
cover the five row units that you're
going to calibrate because it makes it a
lot easier to make adjustments on the
drill if only a few seed cups are full
if the whole drills full it's nearly
impossible to move the thing once it's
been set so what you'll do is just put
enough seed in there to fill up the seed
cup and do that for each of the row
units that you're going to calibrate
once you get the drill primed all the
seed cups are full of seed and you're
ready to begin go ahead and empty your
catch pan until there's no seed left and
then we can begin the calibration okay
once you get the drill primed and ready
to go you'll enter your seed pan or your
seed cups get them completely empty put
the tubes back in and get it ready to go
now we're going to turn the gauge wheel
15 times because our calibration
worksheet has told us if we turn it 15
times we need to catch so much seed for
the right weight or pound per acre that
we're shooting for so I'm going to turn
the wheel 15 times
okay once you get through with your 15
turns before you get the weight of that
seed you've got to zero out the weight
of your container what you'll do is put
the empty container on your scale and
then hit the zero out button to zero the
weight so that when you add the rice
seed back into this or whatever seed
you're calibrating forward back in there
you're only getting that weight and not
the weight of the seed plus the
container and once you get the
calibration or get close because the
adjustments are going to be so small
it'll be handy to have a ruler one of
these metrics small metal rulers but you
can put on the COG on the outside of the
seed cup all the way against the edge of
the seed cup this number will actually
be much more accurate than using the
number off of the leaper because in many
cases there's a lot of play on these
older drills so it's always better to
use this number in this case we're at
eighteen and a half millimeters so we'll
make small adjustments up or down
depending on what our calibration weight
gives us okay once we get this side
calibrated we might have to make a
couple of adjustments back and forth to
get them the weight that's specified on
that calibration shoot once we've got
that we recommend that you go to the
other side and do the other side as well
carry that number that you get from that
ruler to the other side and rather than
using the number off of the lever use
the number off that ruler and that'll
get you died in a dial in a lot closer
okay once you get the grains real
calibrated write your numbers on this
magnetic sheet that right stick will
provide and keep it with the drill
we recommend maybe putting it on the
inside of the lid so you don't lose it
okay it's also important that once you
get out into the field that you follow
behind the drill periodically and check
behind the drill to make sure that
you're still properly calibrated in the
field okay also there are several other
drills that follow this same type of
format you can calibrate those exactly
the same way it really all comes down to
measuring the gate wheel getting that
information in and determining how much
you need to catch based on the gauge
wheel circumference and the row width
your row spacing once you get all that
done always be sure to check behind the
drill if you've got any question
you can always contact your ricetec grip
or your dealer